the critical decision we made early on  was the animation on the diablos  we wanted to show you some of the shots  so you can see what you saw in tokyo  and then what we've changed it looks  very very close to the game  great so we have a comparison  the rathalos from the movie and the  ratholos from the game  come on with the pact of upcares you  guys made something that he wasn't able  to do in the game development so he's  really happy to see that  and you incorporated so many things that  we discussed so he's really  thankful really impressed if we can  deliver for you  we can deliver for the fans  what the hell is that on our six  what the hell is that on our six  holy [ __ ]  you